hi
actually i'll change my glasses here
uh steve kaufman here um
it's uh
it's a holiday here it's monday easter
monday and i'm gonna go up
skiing yeah there's no snow outside here
i could go golfing today but
today is the last day of skiing up at
cypress so i'm going to go for my
cross country jaunt there for an hour or
two
but first i thought i'd do a video
um people often ask me
what do you think of learning systems
like uh
pimsleur assimil
teach yourself
i don't know rosetta stone and i think
i've commented on this before but i
thought i would do it again because
there was another question uh about this
at my blog the blog by the way is the
linguist on language
which you can google for google my name
and you'll find the blog
okay uh we have had link now for
two years maybe
prior to that we had a system called the
linguist which was only for english so
most of my language learning has not has
obviously not been done at link
so
previously if i was going to start a
language i would begin by buying
one of the beginner books and so i mean
here is one it's the colloquial series
which i enjoyed i got this for my
portuguese
uh
teach yourself is another one i bought a
book on how to learn romanian haven't
started romanian yet
um you know teach yourself i even bought
a teach yourself russian grammar book
which i didn't find very good
um what else yeah i bought myself a
teach yourself russian
typically what i do
is i buy
more than one beginner book for a
language this is before we had link
so
because they cover more or less the same
material because all i want out of those
books
by and large
is the content in other words the
learning content i don't do the
exercises i don't do the drills
i do sk i certainly look at the
i look at the vocabulary lists
you know i mean here for example let's
do that properly you can see there's a
dialogue i've underlined some words in
it they give you a little vocabulary
list
and and so forth but the main thing i
want is i want to be able to understand
the little dialogue by looking the words
up in their vocabulary list and then i
want to listen to it many many times
and so i do that in the teach yourself
series and then i'll get a colloquial
book which covers a lot of the same
vocabulary and i'll do the same the
content of the dialogue is quite
uninteresting but i know that at the
beginning i just have to do a lot of
repetitive listening and i have to look
at their at their word list and i might
skim the grammar explanations but really
skim because i know i won't understand i
won't if they tell me about
uh you know
masculine feminine endings and when it's
this way and that way it won't make any
impression on me but it might help me
get through
the content that i'm listening to
so i think that the teach yourself
series are good for that and i would
recommend i mean even though we have
link and we have some beginning material
at link
there's something about holding on
having a book in your hands you know
holding onto a book and i think both
colloquial and teach yourself are good
uh what else do we have here i have i
bought this uh
you know i have a tendency if i see a
book that i think might be of interest
to me i buy it i don't mind spending
money on books i think books are a great
investment 10 20 30 max 25 dollars and
you've got it and i'll often buy books
that i don't need right away
it's kind of like buying wine for a wine
cellar
and they'll be there and then two years
later i'll all of a sudden pick this
book up out of my you know from my
bookshelf and i'll really enjoy it so
when i see something i want in the way
of books i buy them so i haven't started
on check but i have a book hugo
what else do we have here
asimil
which is popular with a lot of people
i did assimil in russian it was okay
again i don't go for any of their
explanations they have so many notes i
find that all our notes are a
distraction
trying to fill you with irrelevant
information the korean book was
particularly bad
the the russian one was was okay they uh
you know there was a little humor in
some of their dialogues uh it progresses
quite quickly uh what i don't like about
asimil is they don't have a vocabulary
list for each
lesson so you're forced to read the
translation which is less efficient
because i got to look for the words that
i don't understand i don't want the
whole thing translated i don't want
their explanations i just want the sound
and the text but asimil is another
beginner one
you know i bought a berlitz book in
russian don't forget i had all of this
before we had link in russia what i
would do now
uh
you know
i think i would still recommend to some
people that even with link
that many of them may want to have a
little book you can get yourself a
little grammar i mean there are little
grammar books like this
or this series was particularly good it
was recommended
by someone on my who commented on my
blog it's the dover
essential grammar books again i always
recommend getting the smallest possible
grammar book you can find and reading
through it from time to time
um
with russian
uh you know i i uh let's see what else
did i buy i bought a book like this
called 500 rational verbs i never use it
i keep it by my toilet occasionally when
i sit there i leave through it i don't
really remember much of what i leave
through it's essentially a useless book
for me
uh i bought this for russian called
beginners russian reader but i found
reading this stuff boring
and
instead when i found this book here
which is the kreutzer sonata
it's a bilingual book french and english
and uh
you know
the sooner you get on to at least with
me the sooner i find i'm able to access
authentic content i'm so much more
motivated to learn it and i was able to
get the kreuzer sonata
book with the french which to me is not
as nice as having the word list but at
least it gives you the meaning so you
can work your way through it once we had
link i was able to find kreutzer sonata
at gutenberg.org or somewhere i loaded
it into link and from then on i was just
on link
i used
link really with with we have some of
our beginning material that link as soon
as we had link up and running for
russian i didn't need any of the books
and
what i and i'll tell you why that is
like even when i was doing german and
italian 20 years ago i would scour the
bookstores here in vancouver looking for
readers
which had text
and a word list that's all i wanted
because i know it's inefficient to look
up in a dictionary because any word that
you see in a dictionary or in a list
you're going to forget so i would rather
have the word list associated with the
text that i'm reading
and then i have a chance of remembering
and plus it's there right away but the
word lists aren't great because very
often the words you need aren't on the
word list
and half the words on the word list you
already know so it's not
that efficient
and rarely what i was telling before
would i be so spoiled as to have the
sound as well as the text
so to my mind what we do now at link is
just an unbelievable service for free
you can go to the library and there you
have in 10 languages content with
guaranteed sound and text
and all the other advantages you can
save you're connected to a to an online
dictionary you can save words to a
database uh you know we start to
indicate how many unknown words or
anyway i won't go into talking about
link
so in all of that then what am i saying
oh i wanted to say one more thing
insofar as the beginner the beginning
period the first three months
and first three months is kind of where
you get over the unfamiliarity you're
not going to learn anything to keep
you're not going to learn how to say
hello my name is so-and-so and then for
forever never be able to say that you're
going to forget it again so the main
thing is just to get into it
i prefer to have
a textbook
like teach yourself where whatever
explanations there are that i might use
are written for me i read them i forget
them i read them again i don't like
pimsleur i don't like michelle thomas
because i have to listen to the
explanations and because i very often
have to read the explanations of
translations 50 times before they sink
in i can't possibly listen to michelle
thomas explain something 50 times nor
pimpster with their english so the
the kind of audio that i want especially
in the beginning when i am listening 20
30 40 times the same content is audio
without my language or without a
language that i that i know okay i'm
going to stop here
i can talk more on the subject but i
better stop to stay under the 10 minute
limit so thank you for listening i look
forward to your comments